hello everybody
and a wall welcome to the uncle my word
autumn session i am luca guayata head of
the medical affairs for
thermo fisher scientific and once again
given the unprecedented time that we're
still living in
we're going virtual for this meeting on
behalf of all time official scientific
and all my colleague i want to say that
we're very happy to offer you
once again one more time a very
interesting and valuable agenda so thank
you all very much for participating
today
hope you have seen the welcome message
from our clinical sequencing
division president garrett hampton
garrett condenses
all the passion that we have about
oncology testing
and share with you how thankful we are
to all of you our customers our
collaborator
and and he has also outlined our plan
for the future if you didn't have the
opportunity yet
you can ask access garrett's video
message at any time
from the lobby now having said that
it leaves me with a pleasure to moderate
today's session
and indeed i'm looking forward for a
very vibrant discussion
with a highly engaging q a
we have two blocks of live presentation
divided by breaks and after
the last one we will have the chance to
see my colleague
andrew who is connecting live from our
laboratories in california
he will demo our genetics system you
will be able to ask him
question as well as to our speaker who
will be live
in the studio with me at the end of
every block of presentation
and now of course even more uh for you
don't forget to see
the oncoming solution hall all precision
oncology all and our brand new posters
in the posterol after the live
presentation
there will be uh our tamil fisher expert
waiting for you
in the ask the expert room so please
take the opportunity and go and connect
with my colleague
and now with no further delay let me
introduce
the first general educational session
and the first speaker for today dr aaron
tan thank you again very much for
joining us today
enjoy the meeting
so thank you for the invitation to speak
today my name is
aaron tan i'm a medical oncologist
currently working at the national cancer
center singapore
i'll be presenting on incorporating next
generation sequencing
or ngs in an asian non-small cell lung
cancer population
including a cost effectiveness analysis
so these are just the disclaimers and
disclosures
so i start with what is basically a
pretty basic concept that probably
everyone
already understands that cancer is
fundamentally a genetic disease
so on the left we've got a picture of a
brazilian ophthalmologist who
150 years ago was actually the first to
describe
a family with hereditary retinoblastoma
on the right there's a picture of watson
and crick who of course discovered
the double helix structure of dna but i
start with this concept just because
it shapes the way that we review we view
genomic profiling
that genomic profiling is should really
be there to uncover the biology
of disease that then enables us to
implement
precision oncology so really it's more
than just
identifying a biomarker to identify
a treatment for a patient but it's
really there to uncover the biology of
disease
and this is perhaps a subtle distinction
in terms of the way that we view genomic
profiling
but i think important all the same
because it does contextualize the way
that we
view molecular profiling and how it may
be integrated into clinical practice
so the outline of my talk today i'll be
going through
what i feel are some of the key
considerations for the routine
implementation of next generation
sequencing
and that includes clinical utility
feasibility
cost effectiveness and diagnostic
accuracy and obviously i'll be using
non-small cell lung cancer
as the illustrative example for the
implementation of routine next
generation sequencing
so i start with this slide which
basically just demonstrates
a pie chart of non-small cell lung
cancer and the way that
our understanding of different molecular
subgroups within non-small cell lung
cancer has changed over the years
obviously we know that there are
significant proportions of patients
that have oncogenic driving mutations in
genes such as k-ras and egfr
but there are now a whole range of other
smaller proportions of patients that
have oncogenic drivers
or biomarkers in other genes including
mutations
in biraff her2 as well as fusions in
genes such as
alk ros1 and ret but even this
pie chart from 2019 perhaps
underestimates the true complexity of
the different molecular subgroups
for example n-track fusions nrg-1
fusions
are not listed here and of course
there's the emerging immunotherapy
biomarkers
there's pdo one which is already used in
routine clinical practice
but also other biomarkers such as msi
status and
tumor mutation burden and obviously
these
molecular subgroups are important to
identify
because there is an expanding list of
approved and emerging therapies
for non-small cell lung cancer and the
different molecular subgroups
so if we come back to this pie chart
where 10 to 15 years ago
treatment options were largely limited
to cytotoxic chemotherapy
there's now an entire range of different
targeted therapies
immunotherapies anti-angiogenic
therapies
that are approved or have emerging
clinical data in early phase clinical
trials
so it really just underlines how fast
the landscape
in terms of the non-small cell lung
cancer treatment has changed
and how we do need to move forward in
terms of identifying these alterations
in patients
so that they can then receive the most
appropriate
first line second line therapies
so obviously that also means that our
testing paradigms do need to
move with the changing dynamics of the
treatment landscape however currently
the the standard of care testing
paradigms
um would be pretty similar for most
countries around the world
and are still largely limited to testing
for
egfr mutations alkyl rearrangements
and ros1 rearrangements in non-squamous
cell carcinomas
in squamous cell carcinomas many
guidelines still
don't even routinely recommend testing
for these
various molecular subgroups and
oncogenic drivers braf mutations are
recommended in some guidelines around
the world
but obviously there are a whole range of
oncogenic drivers which have approved
therapies or emerging therapies that are
important to identify
so that as mentioned patients can
receive the most appropriate targeted
therapy
and most appropriate um treatment for
improving their their long-term outcomes
so obviously that's where
next-generation sequencing comes in
it has many advantages in terms of being
able to detect
multiple different alterations within a
single workflow
although there are obviously challenges
in terms of how we implement
next generation sequencing in routine
clinical practice
and that's not just limited to the
potential costs of ngs itself
but also the expertise and the knowledge
in terms of
establishing next generation sequencing
within a
pathology laboratory
so that brings me to to i suppose what i
consider to be some of the key
considerations for the routine clinical
implementation of ngs
and as mentioned i'll go through these
four different
key key areas so firstly i'll focus on
clinical utility of ngs
so for that i'll start with a brief
description
of the national lung profiling study
which we conducted here in singapore
it was done under the auspices of the
lung cancer consortium singapore
so this was a retrospective cohort study
conducted in newly diagnosed
treatment naive non-small cell lung
cancer patients
over a period of about 18 months in 2016
to 2017 patients
that had been diagnosed at the national
cancer center singapore
or singapore general hospital and
patients that had
available archival ffpe tissue
so this is the console diagram here
which demonstrates that
there were 174 patients that were
eligible for the study
and of these patients we performed ngs
testing
with dna in 173
we performed rna fusion testing in 119
of these patients
and also pdl-1 immunohistochemistry in
169 patients
so to start with we looked at a
comparative analysis in terms of what
was the routine or standard molecular
profiling
at the time versus the results that we
got from the next generation sequencing
assays
so the routine molecular profiling at
the time included egfr testing
either through sanger sequencing or
cobus rt pcr
and also included what we termed as quad
fish so looking for
fusions in elk roswan and red
and amplifications in met using fish
using fish assays
obviously we compared this to the next
generation sequencing results
and we used what was termed the sstp
panel or the solid
or the somatic solid tumor panel and
this was a dna
based ngs test which looked at 29
different genes which are listed on the
bottom
as well as the rna fusion testing using
a lung fusion panel
as mentioned most patients also had pdo
one immunohistochemistry
to look for the tumor proportion score
so if we look at the comparison between
the standard molecular profiling and the
next generation sequencing results
the first thing to mention i suppose is
that in an asian population
in singapore there were obviously high
rates of eg5
mutant patients so upwards of 61 percent
of patients
had the presence of an eg5 mutation and
obviously smaller proportions of
patients with alkalfusions
ros-1 fusions and red fusions detected
by fish
the remaining patients can also be
stratified in terms of their pdl1
tps listed there and when we compare
that with the next generation sequencing
results we can see that
the next generation sequencing performed
well in terms of the identification
of these alterations but in fact there
were more patients that were identified
as having
oncogenic driving oncogenic driver
mutations in egfr
that were targetable so ngs was able to
identify additional patients who would
benefit from first-line egfr
tki therapy and obviously
avoiding the need for upfront cytotoxic
chemotherapy
or even the combination with
immunotherapy which we know is not
as effective in egfr mutant patients so
this really just demonstrates the
clinical utility
of ngs in an asian population
including an eg5 mutant predominant
non-small cell lung cancer population
so next we'll also look at the
feasibility and cost effectiveness
in terms of implementing ngs and from
our nlp study
we also looked at a cost effectiveness
analysis
so we looked at a couple of different
potential
testing strategies including two of them
which are shown in the diagram here so
on the top panel we've got
sequential or singleplex testing so with
such a high proportion of patients with
egfr mutations
there perhaps can be some argument that
the ideal testing strategy should look
for egfr mutations first
whether it be through sanger sequencing
or pcr testing
and only in the patients that are
negative then performing
sequential ngs testing however the other
testing approach could obviously be
upfront ngs testing
including pdl pdl1 immunohistochemistry
and then allowing patients to go on to
the appropriate therapy
so if we look at i mean the panel on the
right
demonstrates the identification of
actionable alterations
using both testing strategies and we can
see the performance of both
either the sequential singleplex testing
or up from
ngs performed quite similarly
but when we consider the costs of each
approach
in terms of a per patient cost and this
is in singapore dollars
we can actually see that the upfront ngs
approach doesn't add
a significant amount of costs per
patient
really demonstrating that upfront ngs
can actually be
just as cost effective as the sequential
singleplex testing
um in terms of outpatient population
and this is even in as i mentioned an
egfr immune predominant non-small cell
lung cancer population
but there are obviously other factors to
consider as well so on the bottom panel
we've got the turnaround time in terms
of
the time taken for results to come back
and again if we consider the upfront
ngs testing strategy you can see that we
get results back
for most patients within 10 to 15 days
the sequential approach however
can lead to additional time in terms of
the turnaround time
particularly for patients that are egfr
negative
patients that then go on to sequential
ngs can be waiting up to 20 to 25 days
before they actually get any results
back
for their for the presence of targetable
mutations and obviously patients that
are metastatic or advanced non-small
lung cancer
a time period of three to four weeks can
be too long to wait for
for the appropriate results but these
patients can deteriorate within that
time
again some other considerations in terms
of this cost-effective analysis
obviously there's also the uh in terms
of the assay logistics
so just the expertise and the
costs in terms of having multiple
different assays
such as the egfr pcr as well as ngs
whereas with the upfront ngs testing
there's only the requirement for
the ngs itself and there's also the the
consideration of the issue of repeat
biopsies
and tissue attrition so with the
sequential approach
if there's if there's tissue that has
been used for egfr testing
leading to potentially insufficient
tissue for sequential ngs
these patients may then need to
potentially undergo repeat biopsies
which obviously further lengths and
lengthens that turnaround time
so this really demonstrates how the
implementation of ngs
can be both feasible and cost effective
and particularly for non-small cell lung
cancer where there are such a range of
targetable alterations um it can be
an important consideration in terms of
the
its implementation
so finally i'll also look in in terms of
the diagnostic
diagnostic accuracy so for this i'll use
the example of
ret fusion positive non-small cell lung
cancer so red fusions have been
a known target in non-small cell lung
cancer since 2011
occurs in approximately two percent of
patients with non-small cell lung cancer
but hasn't been routinely recommended
for
testing in terms of newly diagnosed
patients
due to the poor efficacy of multi-kinase
rat inhibitors
that's of course now changing and on the
waterfall plot on the right we can see
the results for self-acting which is a
selective ret inhibitor
and we can see quite impressive response
rates in terms of 70 to 80
response response rates demonstrating
how
the treatment landscape is changing and
now
you know these drugs are now approved
increasing the importance of identifying
these alterations
but actually there is no gold standard
for the diagnosis of rat fusions
traditionally fish has been used in much
of the literature but the interpretation
of the fish assay
for rett fusions can actually be quite
challenging
due to the small distance in terms of
the break apart probes
in the fish assay itself and there is
some suggestion that perhaps
ngs testing may have better sensitivity
although there are
other assays and techniques with which
you can diagnose rep fusion such as pcr
but there actually have not been many
large scale studies
comparing different testing methods
so we went back and looked at our um
retrospectively
our cohort of patients with that had rep
fusion
and we identified 64 patients that had
repugnant positive monsoon cell lung
cancer
and we compared the performance of the
fish assay
versus the ngs assay so we identified
out of the 64 patients 13 patients that
had both ngs and fish testing performed
and we can see that actually there were
quite high rates of discordance between
the two assays
furthermore when we looked at the
criteria to
diagnose a fish result as positive
if we considered that there is perhaps
this equivocal
result where only 10 to 15 percent of
tumor cells may be positive on the fish
we can see that over half of these
patients
that had both assays performed actually
had discordant results between the ngs
and the fish
and obviously that can be critically
important for these particular patients
in terms of fish positive only but
negative one ngs
perhaps this could be a false positive
leading to inappropriate first line
therapies
and ineffective first line therapies in
terms of the rep inhibitors
and in terms of the patients that were
ngs positive only
perhaps fish testing may have seen these
patients as false negatives
again leading to potentially ineffective
first line therapies in these patients
we also further went and looked in terms
of how these patients
in terms of their survival and a
majority of these patients
did manage to receive selective tyrosine
kinase inhibitor therapy
um because we had a few of these trials
open at our center
and we can see that patients that had
received
selective reticuli therapy it was
associated with a better
overall survival outcome just
demonstrating the importance of
identifying these
alterations in these patients so that
they can receive
you know effective therapies
so that covers the what i consider to be
the you know four of the key
considerations in terms of the routine
clinical implementation of next
generation sequencing
in terms of um the diagnosis of
non-small cell lung cancer
but obviously there are potentially
further applications of ngs
not only non-tomorrow lung cancer but
obviously in other
tumor types as well and this comes back
to you know the point i made in the
beginning
that really genomic profiling should be
there to uncover the biology of disease
so that we can then identify the most
appropriate therapies for our patients
to lead to better outcomes so one of the
potential applications
is to identify co-alterations that could
be either prognostic
or predictive in terms of you know
selecting therapies
and again we use the example of
metastatic eg5 mutant non-small cell
lung cancer
so when 10 to 15 years ago the options
were limited to chemotherapy
obviously there are now a range of
different options for these patients
and the the treatment landscape is
becoming more and more complex
there's not only you know first-line
egfr tkis
there are different generations of egfr
tkis
first second and third generation
inhibitors there are also combination
approaches
and that have shown clinical benefit in
clinic in
in you know phase three clinical trials
and this includes combinations with
chemotherapy combinations with
anti-angiogenic agents as well
so the treatment landscape is becoming
increasingly complex
and there are already you know baseline
factors that we can use to determine
what might be the best approach
in certain patients so at the moment
clinically
particularly the presence of brain
metastases or cns
metastases can indicate that potentially
third generation egfr tkis
maybe the better first line treatment
option
compared to first generation tkis
but there are other potentially
important
prognostic or predictive biomarkers
perhaps not quite yet
in terms of routine clinical practice
but may in the near future become
important to identify
that includes co-alterations or
co-mutations
you know for example p53 mutations
amplifications in her2 or met
but it may also include potentially
broader genomic traits
including things like genome instability
with whole genome doubling
human mutation burden and potentially
even chromosomal instability
so again we use the example from our non
national lung profiling nlp study
and from that study um the 174 patients
we identified the patients that had
received first line eg5
tki and we can see that
patients that had co-alterations in p53
had shorter progression-free survival on
first-line egfr tki
and this mirrors uh what we've you know
what we know from the literature
and although as mentioned it may not yet
be in routine clinical practice
in terms of how it determines our first
line treatment options
it may in the near future become
important so what else
can ngs provide in terms of
understanding the tumor biology
obviously there's also tumor evolution
in terms of
resistance and the potential for
understanding or optimizing
the sequencing of treatments as well
again
using egfr immune non-small cell lung
cancer as the
example we know that for example in
resistance to third generation egfr tkis
such as osimotonib
there can be a whole range of potential
resistance mechanisms
and the important thing to note is the
presence of potentially
targetable resistance alterations
so just highlighting the example of the
you know three to ten percent of
patients
that have targetable um resistance
fusions so fusions in genes such as
entrac
rhett alk and b raf and obviously there
are approved
therapies for that that target these
resistance alterations and there are
case reports of patients responding
to these targeted therapies if we also
consider
resistance to alk tkis and although this
is
in vitro or cell line data we can see on
the left
a range of different potential alk
resistance mutations
and if we consider for example the
g1202r
resistance mutation on the panel at the
top we can see different alkyl tkis
perhaps this is a resistance mutation
that may only respond
to latin therapy so we can see how ngs
can also be important in potentially
understanding
how our how patients tumors become
resistant to therapies
evolve and how we can then select better
next treatment options
so just the final one to two slides you
know where
where can we see next generation
sequencing coming in
in the future and i think if we come
back again to the
point i made at the beginning that next
generation sequencing is there to
understand the biology of disease
i think you know we will likely see
next generation sequencing coming in in
terms of looking
at the broader genomic profile of
patients
and that includes potentially whole
exome sequencing
and whole genome sequencing but may also
include other multi-omics
layers as well so transcriptomics with
rna sequencing and potentially also
epigenomics as well
so to finish again just coming back to
that central point
that really next generation sequencing
molecular profiling or genomic profiling
is there
so that we can understand the biology of
our patient's disease
and this is what enables us to implement
precision oncology so with that i
thank you for listening and obviously
free
to take any questions or comments as
well
good morning my name is natalie and i'm
an associate consultant in medical
oncology at the national university
cancer institute in singapore
today i'll be sharing an overview of the
role of apartment inhibitors and
relevance of hid testing in
advanced ovarian cancer
so this is a disclosure thermo fisher is
not endorsing or
recommending promoting any use or
application of thermal fissure
scientific products presented by third
parties during this seminar
and these are my disclosures
so ovarian cancer is the most lethal of
the gynecologic malignancies in the
developed world
and each year close to 300 000 new cases
are diagnosed worldwide
advanced cancer diet referring to
stage three and four ovarian cancer
accounts for 17 of diagnosed cases
and this is usually because there's a
lack of effective population screening
programs
and many patients do have non-specific
symptoms at the time of presentation
which may lead to a delay in diagnosis
in the in the published literature we
know that around 75 of all advanced
ovarian cancer patients
are of high grade serous histology now
in our center and in other east asian
countries uh this distribution is
slightly different we tend to have a
higher representation of
clear cell carcinoma subtype patients
but high grade serous ovarian cancer
still accounts for
up to 50 of diagnosed cases in our
center
it's also important to recognize that
high grade serous ovarian cancer is a
molecularly heterogeneous disease
and while tv 53 mutations are ubiquitous
in high grade serious ovarian cancer
we do recognize that around half of high
serous ovarian cancers are characterized
by genomic instability
due to a spectrum of deficiencies in
homologous recombination
dna repair and when we look at the
specific reasons for hr deficiency
or hid we can see that around 20 of
of hid is attributable to germline or
somatic mutations in germline
germline or semantic mutations in brca
one and two and these are central
players in the homologous recombination
dna repair pathway whereby um
30 of the rest of the patients with hrd
are usually related to underlying
epigenetic changes in
bracha 1 or other mutations in other
hr related genes
[Music]
so let's just go one step back and recap
how hr dna repair is important in
maintaining genomic fatality um and we
know that maintaining genomic integrity
is really of utmost importance to
our cells which have evolved a number of
sophisticated pathways to repair
both single-stranded and double-stranded
dna breaks
and these are represented in the green
and the orange boxes on the slide
now single-stranded dna breaks are more
common in our cells and if these are not
repaired efficiently these are
commonly broken down into
double-stranded dna breaks which are
more genotoxic to the cell
so single-stranded dna uh brakes are
usually repaired by
certain pathways represented in the
green boxes and double-stranded dna
breaks are repaired
by dna repair processes represented in
the orange boxes
of the double stranded dna repair
pathways we know that homologous
recombination represents a high fidelity
repair
system that allows for accurate dna
damage
reparation however if a cell is
deficient in homologous recombination
that means that they become more reliant
on other methods of dna repair
such as non-homologous and joining or
single strand annealing and these are
low fidelity dna repair mechanisms that
are error-prone
and these consequently lead to the
buildup of genomic instability within
the cell
now the presence of hid in the cell has
been recognized as a targetable
vulnerability
whereby power inhibitors may be
administered to induce
synthetic lethality in the right genomic
context
part inhibitors are small molecule
inhibitors of part one and part two and
when part inhibitors are introduced
they track part at the sites of
single-stranded dna breaks and
block-based excision repair
and the lack of single-stranded brake
repair often
leads to double-stranded dna breaks
which are more genotoxic to the cell
and in cells that have deficiencies in
homologous recombination
they are unable to repair the
double-stranded breaks efficiently
and that often leads to selective cell
death in the hid affected cells
so understanding this has led to the
development of part inhibitors
and as we can see in the red circle
there are three
different part inhibitors that are
approved for use in advanced ovarian
cancer
and on this slide we have organized
apartment inhibitors in decreasing level
uh by decreasing level of uh pop
tracking potency
uh whereby of these three probabilities
neuropart is
the most potent to trap part one whereas
um hybrid and elaborate have
uh fairly similar part trapping
potencies
now another important question that um
uh
that you know is is being asked is um
what is the best way to define hrdness
or hit positivity amongst high-grade
serious ovarian cancers
and to this day there's no gold standard
assessment
hid is commonly recognized as a spectrum
across high grade series ovarian cancer
and many different tools are under
investigation to see how well they
discriminate
patients who are hid positive versus
negative
now the the first bullet point uh shows
uh two different commercially available
assays that have been developed and
validated on prospective clinical trials
and this would be the foundation that's
in
uh loh as well as the myriad my choice
uh
essay and both of them are available for
prescription for purchase and for
reimbursement in certain countries
uh but aside from these two essays you
know many of
many other different assays undergoing a
pre-clinical and clinical
investigation so the
commercially available myriad my choice
test
uses a next-generation sequencing of dna
and analyzes three factors to come
up with a gis score or a genomic
instability score
and they essentially use three factors
to determine the score
the first factor is loh or loss of
heterozygosity that
indicates the presence of a single
allele the second score uh
the second score is the telomere
imbalance which indicates a discrepancy
in the one is to one ratio at the
telomeres and finally there's a large
scale transition or lst
score that looks at transition points
between regions of abnormal and normal
dna
and the overall hrd score or the overall
gis score is calculated by adding up
these three scores
uh by a certain formula and this gives
actually a continuous score between 0 to
100
and a positive hrd score is defined as
anything that is 42 and above
and this has been tested prospectively
in front line and later line
maintenance settings so
the merit test also provides the tumor
broker 1 and 2 mutation status
the other commercially available uh hrd
test is the foundation medicine
percentage of h and i think it's
important to recognize that the way
the foundation medicine test is uh
developed and
analyzes for hrt is fundamentally
different from the myriad my choice test
now um we're familiar with the
foundation 1
cdx panel this provides ngs of more than
300 cancer-related genes including daca
1 2 and other hiv-related genes it also
provides the percent of a h score and
other biomarkers like the tmb
tumor mutational burden as well as the
msi micro in
macro satellite instability status now
how they measure the loh on foundation
medicine is actually very different to
the myriad test rather than looking at
individual loh events the foundation
that's in test looks at the percent of
the genome that's affected by loh
and this is inferred across the 22
autosomal chromosomes
uh positivity or hiv positivity
is uh is regarded as a score of 16
and above whereas a patient with a
genomic lh score less than 16 is
represented by lh low on this test
result
if the loh score is indeterminable they
will
mark this as lh unknown
so as mentioned earlier um using these
two commercially available assays
um we have seen in key trials across
different
disease settings um that uh the benefit
retrieved by different groups of
molecularly defined ovarian cancer
patients appears to be quite different
again vacuum mutated patients appear to
benefit the most the hid positive braca
one two wild type patients appear to
have an intermediate benefit
and the brachial type hid negative
patients appear to have the least
benefit
across you know different phases of the
ovarian cancer
treatment spectrum so let's look at some
of the key trials that stratified
patients by bracket status and hid
status
and look at the impact of the
stratification on the benefit that was
retrieved by patients
in various outcomes so
the first study i'm going to uh discuss
briefly is the quadra study and this is
actually a study of neraparib in
lateline treatment for ovarian cancer
and this was actually a single
single arm study uh phase two study that
incorporated around 400 patients
and they looked at patients that were
fairly heavily pre-treated that had
relaxed ovarian cancer
and that had three or more lines of
prior chemotherapy
and two-thirds of these patients were
actually resistant to the last line of
platinum therapy
and all patients underwent the myriad my
choice test as well as general embracker
testing
and they were denoted to be hiv positive
if the gis score was more than 42
and patients were treated with daily
neuro at 300 milligrams
the primary endpoint was um the
objective response rate so what we can
see is that amongst patients who are
sensitive to the most recent line of
platinum
and amongst patients who are resistant
or refractory to the most
recent line of platinum there is a very
clear
difference in the benefit between each
genomically
defined group so as we can see the
bracket mutated patients
they have the highest response rate
amongst platinum sensitive patients
compared to the
hit positive patients that had a
intermediate response rate
and the hiv negative patients virtually
didn't respond
um to this strategy and similarly
amongst the platinum resistant patients
although the vaga the response rates in
the market mutated
uh population is uh less than those that
were platinum sensitive 27 versus
39 this was still more than um the hid
positive patients
uh you know within the platinum
resistance subgroup of patients
and again uh the hit negative or unknown
patients didn't appear to benefit at all
now um moving uh forward in in the
disease
in the treatment spectrum again when we
look at patients who have platinum
sensitive
relaxed ovarian cancer there were
several trials that
um showed the benefit of maintenance
part inhibitors after platinum
chemotherapy and
platinum sensitive relapse ovarian
cancer and one of these trials was the
nova trial
and this was actually a randomized phase
three trial that
again took patients with platinum
sensitive relapse gave them chemotherapy
patients who are in cr or pr to the
platinum-based chemotherapy
uh were randomized to neuropath
maintenance
until progression or placebo and overall
the trial was
positive for the primary endpoint which
is progression-free survival
um but what was quite interesting is
that when they uh used the myriad
microscope as well as the genomic
bracket status and actually you know
split the patients into different
subgroups they could
see again that the benefit that was
retrieved by these patients
was quite different so we can see that
the germline bracket mutant patients
had the lowest hazard ratio and the
wider separation between the curves
indicating that they retrieved the most
benefit
in terms of progression-free survival
from the use of neraparent maintenance
and amongst the patients that were
non-braking mutant that is the
brachawal type when they split them into
hit positive and hid negative
again we can see that patients who are
hid positive they have an intermediate
hazard ratio between
the brachial mutants and the hrd
wildlife patients
at hiv negative patients and again the
hid negative patients benefited the
least
although across all subgroups all
patients did benefit
so although the hid test in this setting
was not useful to select patients that
benefit because all patients benefited
as long as they were platinum
are responsive it did tell us that
it would tell us about the magnitude of
benefit that would be retrieved
by a particular patient that is being
treated with such a strategy
so there were two other um randomized
phase three studies that
um did look at uh other part inhibitors
in a very similar way um sorry one was a
phase two study that was the study
nineteen
another was a phase three study the
arrow three study and that um
essentially led to the approval of
recapyrib elaborate and narrative as
maintenance treatment
for relaxed um ovarian cancer that was
in complete or partial response to the
latest king
latest platinum chemotherapy without the
need of companion diagnostic to
uh prescribe the pap inhibitor but um
the the
hid test at this point does inform us
about the magnitude of
pfs benefit that the patient is likely
to retrieve
so this is one of those uh trials that i
mentioned earlier the arrow three study
and this trial instead of using the
myriad my choice test actually used the
fmi percent oh
and it was a very similar trial design
it was a randomized phase iii design
and again they randomized patients to
recap rib after
response to platinum chemotherapy versus
placebo in the platinum
uh mostly platinum sensitive relapse
ovarian cancer
setting and again very similar results
um
all patients benefited from uh the uh
use of a
part inhibitor compared to placebo as
long as they were platinum sensitive
um but again broccoli mutant patients um
benefited the most with the wider
separation between the curves and the
lowest hazard ratio
compared to the bracket wall type and a
hidden negative group
who had the highest hazard ratio amongst
the three subgroups and here they use
the fmi percent log test and again
alu hitchhike was defined as a percent
lh of 16 or more
so again this um you know these two
trials and and another trial
led to the approval of um three
different inhibitors as maintenance
treatment
in relaxed ovarian cancer that is
sensitive to the last line of
platinum therapy without the need for a
specific companion diagnostic
and so just looking at how part and have
inhibited development
in advanced ovarian cancer went up until
june last year
again we can see that in later line it
was approved for bracket mutant patients
in the platinum sensitive platinum
responsive setting it was approved
irrespective of platinum's data
irrespective of hrd status
patients just need to be platinum
responsive and a companion diagnostic is
not required
um and also a bit earlier to june 2019
there was also another trial that
did look at front line maintenance part
inhibitors but exclusively in bracket
mutant patients again showing benefit
and so after june 2019 um again
in order to prescribe frontline part
inhibitor maintenance we just needed
the broca mutation status and we didn't
require a hid test
and um the role of um hid testing uh
really came
after three separate um randomized phase
redesigns were presented at
esmo uh last year um and
i'm gonna bring i'm gonna go through two
of the charles um
uh um that i think uh were the most
impactful
so the first trial was the parlor one
and uh this actually recruited patients
that uh had undergo undergone debunking
surgery either primary
uh debulking surgery or interval
debugging surgery and
these patients all have been treated
with platinum texting based frontline
treatment
as we would do um patients uh would have
received at least three cycles of
bevacizumab concurrent with the
chemotherapy
and if they had responded um to the
treatment and
they were either uh with no available
disease or in complete or partial
response after the
the frontline treatment they were
randomized to either elaborate beth
or bevacizumab with placebo and the
elaborate placebo was given for
two years and the beverages amount was
given for one year and the primary
endpoint here was progression-free
survival
prospectively patients also had tumor
brachial mutation status performed
they also had the myriad mitralis hrt
test performed
now the second trial is the prematrial
and the study recruited advanced ovarian
cancer patients with
uh um but specifically those with a high
risk for recurrence
and uh very similar to the paulo one
study these patients had surgery they
had
first-line chemotherapy and patients who
are either nad
in cr or pr to front line treatment were
randomized to either neuropathy
or placebo and here the nerve work was
continued for 36 months
and was dosed according to weight and uh
and platelet
um and the primary endpoint was also
progression-free survival and they did a
hierarchical
um hierarchical testing in patients with
hid positive
tumors first followed by the overall
population so just looking at these two
trials
this is the distribution of patients who
are brachii mutated and hid positive on
both the prima and the paulo and
uh trials and we can see that um around
30 percent of patients were broken
mutants on both trials which is a bit
higher than
um you know what we expect in the
general population
and the hid positivity was also seen in
around 50
of um both trials okay and this um hid
positivity was
um analyzed using the myriad my choice
test using a gis score of 42 or higher
so that leaves approximately um 30 uh
thirty forty percent of patients being
hr
d negative are hr proficient um um
because around fifteen to eighteen
percent of patients um
had an unknown hid status
okay and these are the results from the
um these two trials so i'm looking at
the paolo one study
um i think um the overall results were
actually
positive in the intention to treat
subgroup um but what was most
interesting is when they analyzed the
results by
hiv status and by the bracket mutation
status
so it was again obvious on this trial
that patients with bracha mutations
on the left-hand side of the of the
slide uh benefited the most
from the use of a maintenance pad
inhibitor after
chemotherapy with a wider separation of
the curves and hazard ratio of 0.33
and patients uh you know on the middle
curve who are hd positive
but who are black or while type these
patients had an intermediate benefit
with a you know also a really impressive
hazard ratio of 0.43
but when we looked at patients who are
married at my choice um
gis score of less than 42 or hit
negative um
you know this population was you know we
were unable to demonstrate a benefit of
adding
elaborate temperatures in that in this
population that has a ratio of 0.92 and
the confidence interval crossed one
and when we looked at the premature that
studied naraparib after frontline
chemotherapy
again when they looked at different
subgroups of patients and the brachial
mutant
patients the hiv-positive bracket
wild-type patients and the hr proficient
patients
again we can see that the degree of
benefit of the magnitude of benefit was
the most in the patients with brachial
mutations
with a hazard ratio of 0.4 again there
was a
a good benefit um but lesser in the
brocco wild type hi d positive
population
and in the hr proficient population
there was still a statistically
significant benefit
um with a hazard ratio of 0.68 a
confidence interval
not crossing one but the benefit was um
markedly less compared to the hid
positive
and the bracha mutant sub groups
and so therefore on both frontline
studies the power one and the primary
one
of um maintenance problem inhibitor
after frontline chemotherapy
in um and all camera patients we do see
that um
when we look specifically at the braca
mutant uh subgroup patients we can see
that the hazard ratios are
uh 0.3 and 0.4
and when we compare this with the solar
one study as mentioned earlier this was
a study of
elaborate versus placebo specifically in
brachial mutant patients
again we can see that hazard ratio is
also fairly similar at 0.3
and so what can be finally concluded
from prima and paulo one
in addition to solo one is that all
patients with brachamutin ovarian cancer
should be offered problem inhibitor
maintenance therapy after frontline
chemotherapy
and this effectively means that all
patients with newly diagnosed ovarian
cancer
really need to have early somatic and
germline bracket testing for us to be
able to
you know adequately define this group of
bracket mutant patients who are really
going to benefit from the use of a
maintenance partner strategy
and again looking at the hiv-positive
subgroup that was brachawal type again
this represents this
group of patients in the white part of
the circle where hiv
positive but non brachial mutants again
uh between the pala1 and the prima
studies we can see the hazard ratios are
also fairly similar 0.43 and 0.5
um and these patients they do benefit
from the addition of
apartment inhibitor as a maintenance
strategy and so
it's it you know effectively these two
trials do show us that
doing a hiv test and trying to define
this group of patients that hit positive
but brachaval type will also help us to
select the right patients
for maintenance part inhibitor strategy
in front line
now for patients who are hr proficient
or hiv negative
the evidence is conflicting between the
two trials uh while the parlor one study
didn't show any benefit for the addition
of elaborate to the
season map for this group of patients
the prima
trial did show that um adding neuraparib
compared to placebo
does improve progression-free survival
uh survival albeit for
a fairly uh short absolute period of
time of two point seven months
and i think the questions that remain
unanswered are you know is this pfs
benefit from your rapper it's
statistically significant but is it
truly clinically significant and in this
high
high-risk population that was enrolled
on prima these are typically the
patients that we would
um uh prescribe that consider
prescribing by the season map too
as um front line and also maintenance we
don't know
if neuroprep is superior to vivisi's map
in this subgroup and i think further
clinical trials algorithm
in this hr proficient subgroup of
patients
and so in april this year we had two new
fda approvals um
and basically a labyrinth in addition to
bevacizumab has been approved for
frontline maintenance treatment for
patients who are
in complete or partial response to
frontline platinum-based chemotherapy
and whose cancer is either brocco
mutated or has
hiv-positive test and
fda also approved the use of naraparib
for the maintenance treatment of all
ovarian cancer patients
um regardless of hiv therapy but again
uh you know going back to this slide
again you know we do ask whether
the pfs benefit is clinically
significant and whether this is truly
the optimal
maintenance strategy for patients who
are hr proficient
so compared to previously where hr
testing was not required to select
patients for private inhibitor therapy
in the platinum responsive setting or in
the leader line setting
we now know that hid testing is
important to help us to select the
optimal
maintenance strategy for patients in the
front line setting
and so to summarize essentially what
what these trials mean is that upfront
broker and hid testing is important for
us to make clinical decisions on
maintenance treatment following
frontline systemic therapy
and patients labor mutants will offer
them apartments and maintenance whether
this is a lab rip or that great plus the
seizure map or in the
if patients are hiv positive we would
also offer them pap and hips and
maintenance and this may be neural or
elaborate plus beverages or map
and if patients are hid negative or
unknown um
well the jury is out in my opinion you
can offer them
that alone nervous alone or enroll them
onto clinical trials
well so again should we be just
prescribing narcotics to all patients
without a broker test or a hid test
technically we could based on fda
approvals
but the knowledge of the braca mutation
mutation status as well as hit status is
still crucial
for us to define the magnitude of
benefit that these patients will
retrieve both in the front line and
recurrent setting
and it's also important for the cascade
testing of kindreds and family members
and prophylactic interventions
especially for those with germline
broca mutations or germline hid-related
mutations
so how should we be testing patients and
to me i think the main strategy is
really to test early
and remember we need all these results
to be available to us
by the time the patients complete
frontline chemotherapy which is uh
usually takes around four to five months
and on paula one patients received at
least three cycles of purposes of map
pre-randomization
concurrent with the frontline
chemotherapy and you know
if if patient undergoes interval
developing surgery we don't give
bethesda within six weeks of surgery
meaning that
we usually omit it with cycle three and
cycle uh cycle four
um and and that really you know gives
you a fairly short time
uh for you to have those results before
um
you decide whether you're going to
prescribe feminism or not
from the time of diagnosis ideally it's
also important to test broadly um
ideally that should be a germline
bracket test and a hid test
where available the fda approved test is
the mirror at my choice essay
some physicians may choose to do somatic
testing
with the foundation 1 panel which would
provide both the
bracket mutation status as well as other
hr related genes
and also provide the presented loh test
although this is not
a technically fda approved companion
diagnostic
um but the idea here is to test as
broadly as possible and
to be sure that we can verify the
bracket status as well as the hiv status
now one remaining unanswered question is
whether or not the percent
loh on the fmi test um can be
substituted for the miriami choice test
uh and uh indeed we don't have direct
con prospective comparative data between
both assays um the
one study i could find um was uh uh
presented at a school this year and this
was a very nice
uh retrospective study from gordon mills
group um and uh essentially the
authors used two different cohorts uh
the first cohort was a
very large cohort of more than 3000
commercial samples in the my choice
laboratory
and the second cohort was um of 176 uh
samples from the scottrock4 trial which
is a frontline
trial in high grade serious ovarian
cancer
and they analyze all samples using the
standard my choice gis score
and they also use published methods to
calculate percentage llh score on the
same samples
they also did a targeted screening panel
for 11 different hr related genes
and tried to correlate these three
methods of picking up hrd
um so to me the most important part of
that presentation was the subset of
samples with wild type braca
because we know that by direct
sequencing we will pick up um
the bracket mutants so to you know it's
it's
to me it's most important to be able to
discriminate the patients who are hiv
positive amongst the brachial type
patients
and what was quite interesting is that
when they um
looked at both methods um they found
that 53 percent of patients that were my
choice positive
would actually be called negative by the
percent loh test
which means that which is trying to
imply that if you did a percent lh test
you might miss up to 53 of my choice
positive
tumors okay um it is one caveat here is
that
um this uh study the the authors did use
the gis cutoff
point of 33 rather than 42. so if you
imagine
you know this line here on in the orange
box if you imagine that being slightly
higher
okay perhaps um the the percentage of
cases being missed may be
slightly less than 53 but we do see that
a fair number of of um
of the of the dots or the cases do lie
in this um this orange box
and so that was my my last slide um i
would be very happy to take any
questions and thank you for your time
and your attention
of um of the other dots all the cases do
lie
and thank you very much again to both
the speakers
once again uh thank you very much dr tan
who's actually an oncology fellow and
resident physician
at the national cancer center in
singapore thank you for your
presentation especially focusing on lung
cancer
thank you as well to dr natalingo who's
associate consultant
at the national university cancer
distinguished in
singapore you might have a little bit of
a
he's actually an oncology fellow and
resident physician
at the national cancer center in
singapore thank you for your
presentation especially ocean on land
cancer
all right so now we can start with the q
a
um the first question it's actually
for dr tan and the question from the
audience is about the discordance
between
fish and ngs for rat testing
so the question is thank you very much
for displaying your paper very
interesting
but how do we move forward with that so
what is your
practical suggestion what people should
do
should they do both testing should they
validate the both of them
uh you know orthogonal testing or would
you say
should i go forward with fish or just
ngs
if you could tell us a little bit more
about that
yeah so i think in you know in our
cohort um
you know we had about half of patients
that were
tested with fish and about two-thirds of
patients that were tested with ngs
there are actually other um you know
testing methods that
are being developed such as pcr tests
so these are all going to potentially
come into play um it's something that
um you know i guess there isn't really a
gold standard as yet
so really does need some you know
further clinical studies to
to really validate which one is the most
accurate and sensitive
i think ultimately you know with ngs
testing in non-small cell lung cancer
you know it's going to become much more
widespread and commonplace
so i think ngs is is going to likely be
the way that most patients are diagnosed
but you know you know pcr techniques
and um may still have a role as well
particularly in
you know selected populations um so i
think it's something that does require
further study
um but you know there may be a role for
for you know
ngs and pcr i think in our experience
the fish assay was not
quite so sensitive obviously we saw you
know significant rates of discordance
um and potentially these are false
positive false positives so
um yeah i think um ngs would definitely
have a role
thank you very much for your question so
you know in other words
given that you were strongly advocating
for having ngs up front this might be
maybe the most likely solution and then
in case there is
uncertainty or whether you are in an
appraisal area
that would be the time when you will
have to go and validate with another
method
but you will still suggest that ngs
should be demanded upfront
to actually test not just for red but
actually also to look for other kind of
yeah definitely i mean i think it's the
the especially in our population you
know in asia where
you know upwards of we saw 70 of
patients will have a targetable
alteration
um you know and and the list of
actionable biomarkers continues to
you know expand and grow um so it's
something that multiplex you know
testing with ngs is something that
obviously can detect all of these now
there are trials you know
rep inhibitors that are potentially
going to use pcr techniques so
you know there will still be some
patients that that may be diagnosed with
pcr but i think
you know if we think about in routine
clinical practice
um you know there's obviously a huge
advantage for ngs
thank you very much again for your
question answer for your answer
and another question for dr natalie um
that's a tricky nice one i really love
to
do to get your answer about this
uh there's a couple of trials now that
are looking for combination between
people are inhibitors and checkpoint
inhibitors
but the question is how does test fits
into this because now you will also need
to look at
a pdl one most likely or even maybe
potentially
a tumor mutational burden nobody knows
whether that it's really a good
biomarker or not let's not get into that
but also what about toxicity
and you know how will the combination
were do you see as a sequential
you know treatment combination at the
same time if you could tell us a little
bit about that
sure um i think that the combination of
um
uh checkpoint inhibitors with part
inhibitors is really very interesting
and as
as we know the tenet here is that the
pop inhibitors need to increase
cytosolic free dna
uh and that triggers a seagusting uh
pathway and a type one interferon
responds
and that's supposed to synergize with
immunotherapy um and i think in several
trials it has shown to be a pretty
attractive chemo free regimen
for example in brachial mutated breast
cancer where they have pretty high
response rates being demonstrated
and similarly in ovarian cancer for the
germline bracha one two
mutated populations that are platinum
sensitive we have also seen on the
medeola trial which is development and
elaborate
that the response rate is around 63
percent
however when we look at a group of
patients whereby there's a higher
clinical need for example in patients
who are platinum resistant
the objective response rates actually
aren't very impressive at all
um there was a trial called the tapasio
trial and that was never plus
pembrolizumab and i think the response
rate there was only around 15 to 18
so i think what's important is um we're
really trying to see
um which groups our patients are really
going to benefit the most from such a
strategy
um although the platinum sensitive
bracket mutated patients benefit
um with a high response rate we also
know that they benefit just as much from
platinum-based chemotherapy
so can um part-plus io which is far more
expensive than just carboplatin
can that really take the place of just
the normal platinum-based chemotherapy
and when and in the space of patients
where platinum's don't work anymore
unfortunately the response rates are
quite low and if you talk about
what's a good biomarker to select for
these patients i think really uh
this is an area of intense research um
the hrd test the my choice test on the
tapasio trial
it actually did not discriminate between
responders and non-responders
and even on the terpeso trial which was
platinum resistant ovarian cancer
the brachial mutation itself also did
not discriminate between responders and
non-responders
similarly studies have been done in
small cell lung cancer gastric cancer
tmb and pdl one you know some some
studies are
show that pdr one is helpful and several
other studies have shown that pdl one is
not helpful
and i think none of the studies have
shown that tmv is helpful so
um that's where we are right now um
there is a very nice publication uh from
the topazio study
on nature nature medicine that they
looked at another
investigational hrd test called
signature three or six three
and that itself did help to discriminate
between responders
and they also did quite interesting um
you know a deep dive into the tumor
immune micro environment and they did
also see that some interferon signatures
that talk about t cell exhaustion they
also help to discriminate the patients
that
respond to the strategy so i think a
good translational work is really going
to be very important um in this space
all right so thank you very much again
also for for for answering this one
and now we're actually getting to the
end of our q a i would like to thanks
once again dr tan and lotsu excellent
presentation
very straightforward both of them
extremely hot topic
and uh also let me thank everybody for
joining this
uh this session now we're gonna have a
15 minute break so
please take the chance to have a coffee
uh or you know also
have the opportunity to visit our uh um
virtual hall uh there's a lot of
questions you can ask to our uh thermo
fisher representative take a chance also
to have a look at the poster
in the precision all and there's a lot
of practical resources and
and data that you can find there so
we'll see us again in this session in 50
minutes
once again thanks to the speaker see you
very soon
thank you